hello everybody Welcome to our
Valentine's Day licensing meeting with
all the love
a bit of housekeeping
um fire alarm procedures if my alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out the building
to the Green in Hawley Square which is
the assembly point please do not use the
lifts officers will assist you and
advisements deemed safe to return to the
council offices
um is there going to be any filming
taking place no no okay mobile phones
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones including
myself are turned off and to silent and
they are not used to make orc phone
calls in this room whilst the meeting is
in progress
um apologies for absence I have
apologies from councilor scoby and
councilor Dennis do I have any other
apologies
uh apologies from councilor ARA okay
thank you
um are there any other apologies
councilor shrub
okay
thank you
um Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of Interest
no
um
minutes of the last meeting please can I
have a member proposed and second at the
minutes of the licensing board
um
hello Abby
um minutes the last Museum please can I
have a member proposed and second that
means the licensing board meeting held
on 22nd of November 2022 be approved as
a correct record
um can I have a proposer
um counselor um
and councilor Huxley thank you
so I'm gonna make a comment oh okay
minutes
um
this is the sort of conclusion it's said
I mean
uh members item five members consider
the officers a report and heard from the
education officer and agreed A Way
Forward
but surely we should publish a decision
what the decision was
that that is correct uh chair I think
what should have happened is we should
have had a full set of of minutes but
then that full set of minutes would be
confidential so we would have had to
take this uh item and uh after the
president public would have been
excluded
um so what you see or what we have here
is the public version but we actually do
have the full set okay okay all right
that's fine
okay so um did um are you able to
forward counselor hopefully the full set
of minutes
okay um we I know I was at the meeting
so I mean I thought just in the Public
Public
um menus it should have a decision
doesn't make sense it hasn't got a
decision
a proper decision what does that mean a
Way Forward
that is correct yeah but I need to check
what the decision actually says uh
because I um I can't remember whether I
was at that meeting or not if the
decision contains confidential
information then again is still exempt
from the present public but if the
decision does not contain
um the confidential information then it
should be in the public domain
um I can check and we can bring back
this item yeah let's bring it back okay
thank you
um all right so agenda item four
um exclusion of public and press I
please can I remember proposed and
second that the public and press be
excluded from the meeting for agenda
item five as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph
seven and part one the schedule 12a of
the Local Government Act
1972 can I have a proposer
because the wing
um can I have
um a
um secondary councilor we'll just
um okay
so if all the public leave and if you
bring
okay okay